hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of Thrones if you'd like to
watch the full episode head over to
youtube com @ / gamespot but if you
gonna keep watching here then please be
aware of spoilers so we had the dizzying
highs crushing lows don't lose tedious
bit kind of fillory lows term which was
your least favorite bit so my main I
hated so I've ranked this I hated
dislike and snow daughter Ellie
tolerated hated yeah dawn everything in
Dorne sand snakes don't disappoint me
yeah I mean I've not read the books so I
don't know if I mean you've said before
that the sand snakes are little cooler
in the books but how about a saunier and
they are they seem like they have their
potential to be about us and the show as
well but they just there's something
about them when they're together they
just did their Bance it's just so
annoying that's the a monster that's
almost everything 001 exactly man
that's the most irritating power don't
like the wasted potential part that you
mentioned like they had the potential to
be super cool and there was a whole bit
where one of them decided to just show a
boob for her own episode I really weird
like white dude and they had a
relationship right oh yeah harem born
ever on yeah for like one episode they
were and I am and then Braun just like I
feel like activate the right is like oh
no people like Braun get him up yeah
yeah that the annoying thing is that
what they what they achieved or what
they did was actually quite important to
the overall story right so they they got
rid of Prince Doran and baby you're not
supposed to you they're not supposed to
but like within this kind of
architecture of this narrative within
within the TV series it's important
because if effectively aligned
themselves with the Tyrells against the
Lannisters and the Lannisters are now in
fact but they did it at the very start
of the season so no one remembers
anything that happened I think you look
very end in the book they did that and
Doran was alive it was like dog Doran
have been a Targaryen my list for years
and he couldn't let them all but and
what were boys Dorn's purpose I don't
know like he literally did nothing he
was they was like I'm well SiC my
brothers well dead he's mental then he
going go gang yeah and then he goes and
that was it and the other thing is like
dawn as a place it was quite
disappointing it was at every major city
in the series so far is they spend the
time to give it an identity right and
they give it like a little time to
present it and give it a personality as
a place like you have King's Landing
beams opulent place and when I fell
being this really cool dawn is like as
far as we know it's hot and yellow don't
do is we know it is that one palace and
there are no citizens like spend some
time just we know there's sand outside
somewhere there are no sense about the
motivations of the bike a lot of the
motivations of the people of the
characters within major players within
the cities can be seen in like the
people right and how they you know how
they loved or disliked among the people
is important to the story whereas with
dawn you've got none of that you like
morley everyone loves everyone in Dorne
except the sand snakes who hate everyone
it's just so weird like and obviously we
had an oberon was the best part of dawn
like and he was and we barely saw him
there he was just a representative and
he was about us and even he screwed up
like an idiot confirm your kills god
dammit cook affirmed I do agree with a
lot of the points you you made the
biggest thing that kind of irked me
though is how Tyrion kind of just didn't
matter like is in everything he did just
kind of got reset when Danny turned up
yeah I think I found about Tyrion is
that like they put him in marine so he
can be with Daenerys when she decides to
come over and he's got his pivotal role
there but they still need to justify
Peter Dinklage being the top billing and
the cast yeah so like every episode
they'll give him like a little speech or
a fun story that doesn't add anything to
the plot or just like an awkward
encounter with grey worm and me Sunday I
know why don't we tell some jokes that
was so all I know and he and he started
a joke and never finished here yeah
that's my biggest season except for
negative seasons I please finish your
joke Tyrion and when they were when the
suns the harpy would being a real pain
in the ass yeah I don't like okay let's
kill him terms like no no no we gotta be
going to secure peace yeah they secure
like a really you know awkward Ted
fragile peace and they turn up procedure
city and that is like gonna kill to him
that one duck yeah so like none of his
actions really made a difference they
said he sent like various disappears and
gets you know dawn on side so he really
did more to me feels like just he was
basically just he was the guy that you
send in to keep the plants watered in
the pets fed when you go on holiday here
and then he comes back ins like yeah
it's alright like you know plans a bit
will t I saw that he helped like breathe
some life back into the city right
that's the one lasting impression that
he left of his of his presence there so
like he got because by the end of the
season like the markets were bustling
again and people out and about they were
right priest
another thing that actually annoyed me
because we expected at least I expected
the red precess to be a big plot point
because she was she was given time in
the entire season 6 trailer with our
cool second red woman then she was like
yeah i'll talk about Danny and then
leaves and then we never see anything
again we just see people be like danny
is spot on mate yeah and right pops and
flags sell sell you eggplants vegetables
don't kill each other and then ate and
then son's happy actually do come back
anyway so again it's just another
inconsequential moment yeah yeah also
the fact that they had to start to ship
miss sunday and grey worm just to make
those characters interesting to give a
little bit more likely they were put on
copper beforehand right like David they
were doing the play in season 5 yes he
was looking at having a wash yeah that
counts for me that's enough of me but I
didn't really like his season was like
just how I is storyline in Braavos
culminated I thought it was a bit
disappointing I guess because like you
you see her getting whacked by the by
the wave like week in week out you see
the wave just completely kicking her ass
and then she does her weird out of
character thing that I don't I'm not
entirely convinced the way for the
fallen for because she's so out there
with it and she's you know slamming
money down being really obvious walking
around you know I don't think the wife
is that stupid but then so when you get
to that final confrontation scene where
she's like you know she cuts the candle
we as the viewer don't get the
satisfaction of watching the wife died
we just get see her face with the eyes
gouged out put in the Hall of faces that
annoyed me and also just the way that
she sort of you know like Jack and
brought her to the house of black and
white and trained her and you know try
to make her no one and then he finally
says you are no one and she goes all
right peace out that's it you know why
are you absolutely nothing by and just
leaves and jetpacks away again I mean
we've spoken before about how I'm gonna
come out and say how bad the passive
passage of time is yeah in this season I
think i er
yarra and Dion and particularly virus or
ones that really suffered from that just
because so mmm a lot of people a lot of
people mentioned you know obviously
there is time passing in between these
but I mean there's ways of showing that
and this season the show has made no
attempt of doing that like for anyone
most people will will see these things
before you know most people won't pay
too much mind to it but for people who
are is does come off as feeling a bit
inconsistent a bit weird with the
passage of time and it at the same time
and stuff like flashbacks and time
traveling all this other crazy stuff
happening you're like what is its kind
of like it excuse your perspective of
time I think it's something that we
bring up a lot and a lot of people like
come on guys but we're like it's an
important thing right yeah it took us
out like segwaying a bit from the area
thing but when we saw various it took us
out of the moment so so much that we
were like is your faceless man that he
uses travelled real fun real fast ya
know then we just worked out that you
buggin I mean thing about arias thing as
well is that we spent however log in the
house black and white and we're still no
closer to really understanding how the
Faceless Man theung work yeah a face off
and just pull a face off would you need
to get one from the wall cuz then how
would you take that to Westeros because
like we did not need to keep moisturised
in a bag or something just a simple AAG
bag full of like formaldehyde I got one
I've just realized mmm have you guys
seen face off what if he was don't
revive a man doesn't know Nicholas oh my
god I have to go guys there's a thread I
need to write Oh to read it I found
Victor it
you